E
LEFT.
SAY IT AIN'T SO.
RAYMOND ARROYO IS HERE FOR
FRIDAY FOLLY.
FIRST, LAST NIGHT SPECIAL
COUNSEL JOHN DURHAM DROPPED HIS
SECOND BOMBSHELL IN TWO WEEKS.
HE ISSUED SUBPOENAS TO ONE OF
THE MOST POLITICALLY CONNECTED
LAW FIRMS IN THE COUNTRY.
IN 2016, THAT LAW FIRM
REPRESENTED THE DNC AND THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN, WHO THEN OF
COURSE USE THE FIRM TO FUNNEL
MONEY TO FORMER BRITISH BY
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
CHRISTOPHER STEELE IN TURN USE
THE FUNDS TO FUND HIS PHONY
DOSSIER ON DONALD TRUMP.
THIS COMES JUST TWO WEEKS AFTER
THE FEDERAL GRAND JURY INDICTED
FORMER LAWYER MICHAEL SUSSMAN
FOR LYING TO THE FBI DURING THE
2016 MEETING THAT HELP PROMPT
THE TRUMP RUSSIA PROBE.
WE ARE NOT SURE WHY IT'S TAKEN
HIM SO LONG TO DO THIS BUT WE
MAY FINALLY, FINALLY BE CLOSE TO
LEARNING JUST HOW FOR THE
CLINTONS AND THEIR ALLY WENT IN
THEIR EFFORTS TO DESTROY
PRESIDENT TRUMP, HIS CAMPAIGN
AND HIS PRESIDENCY.
AND WHEN THE TRUTH COMES OUT WE
WILL FINALLY SEE HOW INVESTED
THE DEEP STATE WAS.
THEIR GOAL WAS TO FRUSTRATE THE
TRUMP AGENDA AND PUT HIM ON THE
DEFENSIVE FROM DAY ONE.
AND AS WE ALL REMEMBER, THE MAIN
FILLINGS HERE WERE AIDED AND
ABETTED BY A CORRUPT LEFT-WING
MEDIA COMPLEX THAT FANNED THE
FRAUDULENT RUSSIA COLLUSION FOR
YEARS.
BY THE WAY, NONE OF THOSE
MEETING FOLKS DECIDED TO RESIGN
AFTER THIS.
AS FAR AS I CAN TELL, THERE HAS
BEEN NO ACCOUNTABILITY.
SOUND FAMILIAR?
SOUNDS LIKE JUST WHAT WAS
HAPPENING AT THE BIDEN PENTAGON.
AND WHEN THE DURUM SUBPOENA NEWS
DID BREAK, HILLARY'S
COLLABORATORS IN THE PRESS, THE
KIND OF JUST DECIDED TO DOWNPLAY
IT OR JUST IGNORE IT ENTIRELY.
LAST NIGHT, ABC AND CBS FOND
OVER BIDEN'S MOVES TO SAVE HIS
MEGA SPENDING BILL AND KEEP HIS
BORDERS WIDE OPEN AND THE DURHAM
PROBE DIDN'T MAKE
"NBC NIGHTLY NEWS" EITHER BUT
THEY DID FIND TIME TO DO A VERY
IMPORTANT FEATURE ON THE LINEUP
FOR THE SUPER BOWL HALFTIME
SHOW.
BUT COME ON, IT'S
UNDERSTANDABLE.
SNOOP DOGG OVER HERE, EMINEM
VERSUS BORING OLD -- OVER HERE.
MAYBE IT IS TIME TO STRIKE THE
WORD "NEWS" FROM
"NBC NIGHTLY NEWS" AT THIS
POINT.
MORE LIKE NBC NIGHTLY
DISTRACTION.
OF COURSE, AND BC SPEND YEARS
DINING OUT ON THE TWISTED
RUSSIAN CONSPIRACY.
>> DONALD TRUMP WAS TRYING TO DO
BUSINESS WITH RUSSIA AND SIX
MONTHS LATER RUSSIA IS TRYING TO
HELP THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
IT'S NOT VERY COMPLICATED.
>> THIS IS NOT HOW PRESIDENTS
BEHAVE.
IT'S A DARK MOMENT IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
>> "THE NEW YORK TIMES" CALLS
WASHINGTON, 48 HOURS LATER THE
TRUMP DOMAIN VANISHES FROM THE
INTERNET.
>> ONE THING, THE ALPHA SIDE OF
IT DISAPPEARS.
THEY CALL TRUMP AND THE ALPHA
SIDE OF IT DISAPPEARS.
>> Laura: SURELY CNN GAVE THE
DURHAM DEVELOPMENTS OF THEIR
DUE?
>> SEEMS LIKE THEY'RE NOT
DELIVERING THE BIG FISH THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND BILL BARR
PROMISED.
>> AFTER TWO AND A HALF YEARS OR
SO THERE HAVE ONLY BEEN TWO
INDICTMENTS AND THEY HAVE REALLY
BEEN THIN.
>> Laura: WHAT IS MAN IS THEIR
CREDIBILITY AND OBJECTIVITY.
IT IS NONEXISTENT.
WOLF BLITZER, ONE OF THE
SLIMIEST GUYS IN THE ONGOING
DRAMA.
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR
ANDREW MCCABE.
SPEAK OF THE ACTION OF THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL AFTER TWO YEARS
OF INVESTIGATING HAS FOUND
ESSENTIALLY NOT MUST, AT LEAST
NOT YET?
>> THAT IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THERE IS REALLY VERY LITTLE HERE
RELEVANT TO WHAT HE SUPPOSEDLY
WAS HIRED TO INVESTIGATE.
THE SUBPOENAS REALLY HOLD THE
FBI MORE IN THE POSITION OF
VICTIM RATHER THAN THE SUBJECT
OF AN INVESTIGATION.
>> Laura: THE SPIN NEVER ENDS.
REMEMBER AND HE IS ALWAYS GOING
TO PLAY THE VICTIM, THOUGH.
THE FBI, INTEL AGENCIES, MEDIA
AND DISHONEST DEMOCRATS, THEY
DID INCALCULABLE HARM TO THE
PRESIDENCY AND THE PEOPLE'S
FAITH IN THESE INSTITUTIONS AND
NONE OF THE GUILTY PARTIES AND
THE SAGA, NOT THE PRESS OR THE
INTEL COMMUNITY, HAVE LEARNED
ANYTHING OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS.
SINCE WE DISCOVERED TO BE RUSSIA
PROBE WAS A FRAUD FROM THE
OUTSET, IT WENT ON TO TARGETING
INNOCENT AMERICANS WHILE
DISMISSING BIDEN'S CONFLICTS OF
INTEREST ON CHINA AND HIS
GENERAL INCOMPETENCE AT MANAGING
THE AFFAIRS OF OUR NATION.
IT'S A COMPLETE AND ONGOING
DISSERVICE TO THE HARDWORKING
PEOPLE OF AMERICA WHO DESERVE TO
KNOW THE TRUTH ABOUT T